[Music]
Shan Shan I know you're bummed I talked
to mr. Connery you're one of the biggest
stars in the world you can make a few
mistakes every once in a while your
friend Michael Crichton already sent me
a bounce-back script it's called
Jurassic Park you're the guy who owns
the park if you're not willing to take a
slightly smaller role consider retiring
extraordinarily dangerous that's perfect
your marvel has some major plans I don't
know I got a script here called the
matrix you play a mentor named Morpheus
and it's supposed to be really
cutting-edge always reference that yes
okay look Shawn I'll level with you I
have a script here for Lord of the Rings
one of the most famous books ever
written they're filming three movies all
at the same time something never done
before in cinema and they're offering
you the role of Gandalf you have to be
an idiot named absolutely insane to turn
down a surefire blockbuster series like
this
[Music]
I think I should retire I think you're
an idiot
[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guide
remember it so you don't have to some
people have a winning streak others have
a naked streak Sean Connery has both
after years of being one of the most
charismatic and attractive actors of all
time something finally started to
crumble when he turned down several
blockbuster hits and instead shows
awkward avenues of awful T but the one
so famously bad that he left acting
shortly after is an angry abomination of
a sness I like a words today called the
League of Extraordinary Gentlemen
[Music]
based on the comic by Elham or the guy
who do Watchmen directed by Stephen
Norrington the guy who directed blade
and starring the guy who inspired the
greatest celebrity jeopardy episodes
ever made how can this not be friggin
amazing well it found a way and folks
have been regretting this extraordinary
dumb hood for 15 years has it warranted
all the hate it deserves
well Connery decided he had one more
film in him after this I guess it can't
be that bad can it
let's find out for ourselves this is the
League of Extraordinary Gentlemen
oh I guess that Disney merger didn't go
as well as expected they can survive
Cleopatra but not the mouse and opening
crawl says what every opening crawl says
no really you can replace them all with
things suck some asshole might make it
better but things suck it's easier than
following the Phantom Menace text yeah
I'm not really paying attention to the
starring credits when a goddamn tank is
on screen
this is especially frustrating because
it distracts from the police's brilliant
tactical strategy oh it didn't work once
there try it again oh I think you're
asking polite enough as a tank it has to
stop
after you say hole two third time you're
gonna say hole two third time aren't you
you deserve this wily coyote death
thank God newspapers were written like
tweets back then as Germany says nine us
and the culprits are rounding up every
textbook mad scientist to say every
textbook mad scientist cliche you know
can't one of these supervillains ever
answer with kawaii it's Pleasant the
weather's nice it's really all you need
I would identify more of the villain if
he said he just wanted kawaii
well I can see why they focused mostly
on his eye is the rest of it looks like
a basement cosplayer who couldn't fit
into his costume so he grabbed whatever
leftover scraps didn't have cheeto dust
all over him yeah this is my dirty
destro Maz my dirty Spartan armor my
dirty Kirillov deville coach I am the
United Arab the destro fear me but
Germany now attacked and Europe
threatening to go to war we logically
cut to Kenya as in Kenya tell me why the
hell I'm supposed to give a shit was
Quartermaine ryan gosling Affleck here
is looking for a man named Alan
Quartermaine and tell me for a
brain-dead second you would actually
believe this is him do I have the
pleasure of addressing Alan Quartermaine
yes you do sir indeed you do yes that's
it and you want to know what I'm not
into lying I'm totally not into that
if only we could figure out who the real
Quartermaine was it could be anyone even
that Sean Connery shaped man to the
right the Empire needs you do I need the
Empire
I'm Quartermaine Oh movie got us an idol
is useful for keeping the story seekers
at bay is he
you would be bad at it this
representative of the British government
says he needs him because war is on the
horizon countries set at each other's
throats baying for blood it's a powder
keg war with whom exactly a world war
and by world I mean mostly Europe which
is pretty much the world to us stories
of your exploits have thrilled English
boys for decades so many directions I
could take that joke mr. Murdock yes
these assassins here shoot the wrong
Quartermaine Christ you could see a five
year old girl is Quartermaine and they
fall for it and they have themselves a
shootout pretty skill knifeman and a lot
of sean connery to hit that was pretty
embarrassing
nothing like a wino impaling at a rhino
called save yourself ya son of a bitch
yeah but there's one assassin left what
do I smell bad
fearing the war will come to Africa
Connery agrees to help and is flown to
London to meet up with the man in charge
mm no that's not a James Bond joke
that's really what he's called my
superiors call me am keeping Connery has
a look that's like Oh dumb I get it no
you think that's bad listen to the joke
that precedes it you made good time
getting here not as good as Phileas Fogg
and you think that's bad Fanta spell
that's who you the dumbass audience
where it's from around the world in 80
days even that laughs it seems to say
we're making this kind of movie ha I
should have mailed the script to the
Marx Brothers Tommy can barely even take
the title being told to his face newest
generation of the League of
Extraordinary Gentlemen League of what
no seriously when do we start filming
the real movie they've discovered these
attacks are all the work of one man who
calls himself a phantom very operatic
God he's introduced to the league first
with Captain Nemo Alan codomain Captain
Nemo rumor has it that you're a pirate
i white according to most movie versions
he's also created by the Invisible Man
and Mina Harker and seeing how M is
played by Richard Roxboro who plays the
villain and God and everything I'm just
gonna guess and say the M stands for
Moriarty would you prefer more you don't
even care the head you know they're lame
enough to do it what in God's name is
that I call it
auto movie okay this isn't Dora the
Explorer you can say new words at a
regular pace auto movie or car this is
my first mate call me Ishmael
Jesus Christ Hey look the makers of this
comic we're so embarrassed to be in it
they just sent their names in fact wait
Alan Moore isn't playing the villain I
think that's the biggest twist so far
what dumbass book are you from mr.
Dorian Gray asked us dude the question
you're missing a picture mr. gray and
you don't miss a thing do you know
sometimes good scripts for example I
miss those are locked so we go from one
big building where we're sitting around
talking to another big building where
we're sitting around talking squee we
all of us have traits useful in this
endeavor
a hunter scientist even Skinner has
stealth Cheers
oh look we can see the drink go down his
throat shouldn't we see all the food and
drink he's ever had then like over the
days or weeks whatever thank technically
be seeing it turn into movie but Ivan
the blast shows up to try and take out
our heroes but give to all special
one-time invitation join me you know the
mask is supposed to cover the ugly part
right
Connery gets a wing from someone who's
on his side though and another shootout
commences Henry did you survive will
never be the same at that ladder oh my
god this guy has a sword and all we have
are machine guns and that's nothing
compared to this guy came you know the
stormtroopers defeated by the Ewoks are
probably looking at these guys saying
what are you I'm white prince I'm
complicated oh that is so something
white prince would say I mean it reveals
her power to as apparently she's a
vampire from Dracula
I don't know everything else is spelled
out who's this sexy Don Quixote and you
are special agent disorder oh cool did
you trick some kids too painting out the
bullet holes from Dorian's suit hell
let's go you're in thanks travel to
Paris to get one last recruit dr. Jekyll
ripping off van Helsing or did Van
Helsing rip off this you know what
they're both shitty movies we all lose
okay Fred that the effects on him are
legitimately pretty good and I also like
that Nemo sort of the ocean actually
looks like a sort of the ocean you know
cloud swords but still sword but most of
the movie is just people standing around
yapping that would be too bad except the
knife and talking like they're
interested in what they're saying these
are the most famous characters in
fiction each one of them has a book
centered around them yet they all talk
in the dollars roars and the most mono
of tones what I was surprised you
ultimately joined the league so it's
clear with da Vinci's blueprints and
enough explosives I mean to undo the
flaws in my character your past haunts
you
pagemaster developed these characters
better there's supposed to be a love
triangle between Mina and actually
everybody but no one has any chemistry
even as friends is gonna sink the whole
city and the biggest insult is as a
comic book movie think about what you
can do with this idea maybe the vampire
takes Jekyll's potion maybe Tom Sawyer
can turn invisible
maybe Nemo and Quartermaine can invent
some new kick-ass weapons combined these
characters work off of what they know
come up with some really interesting
ideas but nope none of that is taking
advantage of they just all sit around
and talk at a very low tone like they
need a goddamn nap
they're supposed to have the chemistry
of the x-men but they have the dozing
effect of nyquil so you'll attack the
conference by sea thank you for your
contribution so far
bang I mentioned some of the greatest
comic book characters of all time got
together and this is all they did is it
a good book yeah
really what are you ready my men I bet
you lead an interesting life not really
should we like talk about our passions
or our dreams why either of you see
League of Extraordinary Gentlemen
yeah that's sucked
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
the league makes it to Venice to
apparently stop a bomb that the Phantom
is going to set off no one will ever see
us come on it's not like this thing can
go underwater or anything got this Tibet
by the way have I gone colorblind or if
they're not one spectrum of color in
this god damn fireworks have no color
and that's their only purpose to go boom
and have color maybe the Phantom is a
genetic fusion of the villains from
Rainbow Brite you know that makes too
much sense but more the one bomb goes
off sinking a ton of Venice's buildings
the next you can interrupt the chain of
destruction no room for error but I tell
you it could Oh God
even with explosions go off they just
talk it should be the frigging League of
Extraordinary conversations except the
conversations are boring too we did
finally get some bland action though as
the new device called Auto movie
remember a device so new they say it
like this Auto movie can be driven
perfectly by Sawyer who despite never
seeing one there being a one before I
can pull a fast and furious trailer
pretty quick out of his ass
no no I swear this is the first time
I've ever driven this automobile
[Music]
he'll be fine Jesus Christ he really is
fine give him the scratch at least I was
half joking they stopped the rest of the
bombs as Connery hunts the Phantom down
to a cemetery of his failed movie
choices look there's medicine man weak
you know it's pretty funny him calling
Connery week when he's skipping away in
fear like the naked guy from life Oh
Brian you don't look like the image of
strength here buddy you look like a
missing Hobbit dwarf boring son of
snoring but it turns out the Phantom is
the fat Emma that's right it was em wear
a mask under a mask you know for
criminal mastermind you really didn't
need to do a lot of this you had a
really nice place to hang out there's
literally no point in you going to all
these places except to make monologues
about wanting to well sorry what's this
guy's plan again of the scratched audio
recording given a scratched film
reference despite it not being recorded
on film should explain and now I've been
true to the girls said to me war will
come sooner or later as he never devoted
summer into water it is over for you I
think between those guys Clinton
eyebrows and his Peter Dinklage bonking
blames Shatner voice he could be the
world's hammies magician Act even the
league itself there is no league never
was it was the rules any closer to my
goal am i over here or am i over here
I'm actually right behind you just
kidding out in front you the whole time
but I fooled you for a second didn't I
it appears he started this war because
he saw war is inevitable anyway hey
here's an idea as test beating it up why
don't you goddamn stop it you're freakin
mastermind nevertheless he wants to be
the most powerful force when that war
comes so he still samples from all the
League Jekyll's potion visible man skin
Mina's blood Connery's accent he's got
them all it's a little hard to pay
attention though as through all of this
Hyde is making faces in the mirror oddly
enough both figuratively and literally
what fool reveals he's trying to join me
for the game
while I rambled on I honestly don't see
how making faces to the side enhances
anything especially after 20 minutes of
it will you knock that off you've been
doing that the entire review just
doesn't see the necessity of it I don't
it turns out and then Dorian loved to
bomb on the sub as well leading to the
most witty of parting lines bombs Lea I
got that from a Captain Crunch box the
bomb goes off as we see white with such
a dumb idea to bring all these
characters together because well they
can work together to become even
stronger yeah why the hell didn't he
just visit them individually to get the
samples they'd be less powerful without
all the supernatural backup not that
they're acting kids are they stronger
when they're together congratulations
you win the RepRap awkward scream award
they obviously stop the ship from
sinking and bring it up to the surface
to figure out their next move bon voyage
I just got it oh we're getting a signal
Gouri only mixed remarried gentlemen
we'll figure that out Oh even translate
what it says dot dot dot dot dot dot dot
all ahead well they're told where Emma's
going and follow him in the submarine to
a secret hideout doing activity security
he's invisible man sneaks into his
hideout to report back what he finds of
course being completely naked and
somehow surviving the goddamn freezing
cold yo I saw snow on his dinghy he says
in the hideout there's a ton of Tanks
oculus subs and metal super suits being
made to take over the world well at the
very least were promised a kick-ass
climax of none of those tanks
none of those subs and only long oh
those friggin suits being used but it's
ok because we get this weird shaving
edit in the middle of the action
of course that's how we got rid of this
moustache it's all falling into place
thank god they focused on that ok credit
that there are two cool things in this
climax one is this line we have trouble
I call it sport that's just awesome and
the other is this guy as far as I know
he was never introduced before but look
at him oh my god having fun in this
entire movie it only gets better when he
takes hides potion and covers himself
with it
[Music]
this movie is doing everything right
with this character this is the exact
weird-ass guy I want to take this potion
in the exact weird-ass way I want him to
take that potion leaving - holy shit
look at this why were we getting this
movie the whole time you're not though
boring ass conversations are on the way
do not move or would you prefer
professor James Moriarty I prefer a
surprise that actually surprises like
just how bad never say never again was
but I guess this will do actually no it
won't but the movies made and escapes
what Dorian fights off Mia ever clearly
doesn't kill her like that nowhere near
her heart but she surprises us by
pointing out that was nowhere near her
heart
this time you missed oh that's right
it's a man's heart in his stomach if you
were a guy you totally be dead she shows
in the picture killing him off while
supposedly the Invisible Man comes to
help Sawyer it's okay Skinner what makes
you think I'm Skinner what makes you
think it was smart to tell him that
dumbass you could have had him dead in a
second now he's just weirded out that
there's two invisible schlongs in the
open during this climax Connery meets up
with em and tries to finish him off oh
no he has an S word the others like Miko
tonight you can't kill the future
[Music]
Oh Lord will the villain make it why are
you making us concerned about him and
reveals though that he has Connery son a
Sawyer yep his son they borrowed from
the Jurassic world falling Kingdom book
of weak-ass twists and em gets the jump
on him
oh I didn't know Batman counted as a
fictional character you could have in
this world
Lorne knows I'd actually welcome an
Austrian mr. freeze just to see someone
smile
Sawyer finishes em off but apparently
can't save is out of nowhere father
relationship in time may this new
century be your son
Wow even the main characters death
seemed olace shit he doesn't look like
he died he looks like he was shown a
clip of him singing from Darby O'Gill
and the little people she is my dear my
darlin one my smile and I'm big Ireland
so they bury him back in Kenya don't
worry I'm sure dr. Frankenstein will
drop by to whip them into shape
I have long hidden away from the world
now I wish to see it a new West century
- you're all welcome to join me the
funeral on this is like yeah ok cool I
miss him I guess but fear not as
apparently Kenyan shamans have cured
death turns out the secret was dancing
dancing cures death um like and share
kept the downside this he's reincarnated
as a CG dragon and still can't sing and
that was the League of Extraordinary
Gentlemen I'm sure it tried its best
your vast losers always whine about
their best
winners go home and fuck the prom queen
I will go through all of Sean Connery's
IMDB page everyone seems half a week
it's visually colourless the effects are
hitting this it's just an all-around
boring movie I can't say it's anywhere
near the worst I've seen
not even close it's just dull and
uneventful only these characters are
from the greatest stories ever written
but having them all together doesn't
seem to make any of this work that's
gotta be some bad writing if you can't
make them leap off the screen as they
originally leapt off the page and if
anyone is foolish enough to do a sequel
in the future it had better look
something like this now that'd be a
final film for Connery to go out on I'm
not Nostalgia Critic I remember so you
don't have to
[Music]
[Applause]
auto movie
hey dub Walker here doing the charity
shout-out and this week we are doing
Doctors Without Borders Doctors Without
Borders is an international medical
humanitarian organization created by
doctors and journalists and France in
1971 today Doctors Without Borders
provides aid in nearly 60 countries to
people whose survival is threatened by
violence negligence or catastrophe
primarily due to armed conflict
epidemics malnutrition exclusion from
health care or natural disasters they
provide independent impartial assistance
to those who need it the most
they also reserve the right to speak out
to bring attention to neglected crisis
as well as challenged inadequacies or
abuse of the aid system and to advocate
for improved medical treatments and
protocol this is an international
movement made up of nineteen associative
organizations so they've gotten a ton of
work done all over the world if you look
at their site in their YouTube channel
you realize there's so much suffering
everywhere and these people bravely
enter these dangerous places to get
innocent people the help that they need
click on the link and see how you can
help these wonderful folks save so many
lives
you